let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right it's been announced by the
debate commission that trump and biden
will have their mics muted during the
last debate this thursday
uh this thursday night they'll be
debating final debate i believe and
they're gonna have their mics muted
um not for the entire debate which
actually i wouldn't wouldn't maybe be
such a terrible thing
but uh you know while one is speaking
and giving their two-minute spiel
um the the other one's gonna have their
mics muted
now trump has protested this decision
and said that it's very unfair quote
unquote
uh and a lot of conservatives are upset
about it
because they see it as a as a you know
something that's
being done specifically targeting trump
which of course it is
and it's a and they see it as something
that's supposed to hurt trump which of
course it is but my point is that
i although it is targeted at trump i
don't think it's going to hurt him i'm
actually in favor of this i think it's
going to help trump
my biggest frustration in the last
debate was that trump would not just
shut up and let biden speak and bury
himself metaphorically speaking
with his own words we know that biden
struggles to string together
two minutes worth of coherent um
you know of two minutes worth of
coherence in general we know he
struggles to do that just as i clearly
struggle to do it too
so let let him do it when you only give
him
30 seconds to speak he's going to sound
like he's really with it give him the
full two minutes
that's good strategy now if trump
had a certain measure of discipline and
self-control then he could just do that
without the mics being muted
but he but he doesn't so that's why it
helps to have the mics muted so i
i think in the end it's gonna it's gonna
help trump
um although of course
in reality it it he's right it is an
unfair decision the fact that it's
targeted to him
and also it this is not really how a
debate's supposed to work
i'm talking from a purely political
optic sort of standpoint i think it
will help trump ultimately but it's all
it does
defeat the purpose the the actual real
purpose of a debate which is
you're supposed to debate there's
supposed to be a back and forth
that's what a debate is all this stuff
these things we call debates
none of them are debates they don't
qualify
think about if you've ever been in a
real debate with which if you're a human
being you probably have
with with just another person like in
your living room this
is not how it works it isn't okay i'll i
will i will state my case for two and a
half minutes and then you could go and
then we'll go back no it's
then we'll have 30 seconds for rebuttal
and no you just you just go back and
forth and you have a conversation that's
what the debate should be but
that's never going to happen so we make
do
i suppose uh number two speaking of
trump he has uh
picked up an unexpected endorsement
another rapper another famous rapper 50
cent
has come out in support of trump so
maybe
so you got kanye west 50 cent maybe they
maybe they'll have a collab
next in time for the election who knows
um
50 sat on instagram posted a screenshot
of biden's tax plan
showing that people in his tax bracket
will have to pay 62
of their income and he had this caption
he said what the f
uh vote for trump i'm out
or first of all a lot of emojis here so
this is upsetting me
right now this is a i've already made my
point here but this is a grown this is
if you're watching this right now on
youtube the emojis do they help enhance
the point at all
he says i'm out of new york the knicks
never win anyway and he's got a little
emoji of a guy running
yeah i get it you know you've already
told me you're leaving i understand what
leaving is i don't need it i don't need
an illustration
you know what leaving is are you sure
because i got i'll draw you a picture so
you no i don't need that
anyway he says i'm out of new york the
nick the knicks never went anyway i
don't care
trump i don't care if trump doesn't like
black people
62 percent are you out of your effing
mind
now obviously the left is is having a
fit over this
but you know what leaving aside the
emojis and everything
this is a very normal very adult
reason to vote a certain way
people on the left are upset at 50 cent
and say oh you're so selfish
you're so selfish that you want to keep
your own income what
you say you don't want to work
in order to give more than half of your
income to the government so they can
squander it
you selfish bastard no normal
adults who work for a living
have responsibilities maybe have family
to take care of
we prefer to keep as much of our own
money as we can
not because we're a bunch of ebonies or
scrooges maybe we are that's our own
business
that doesn't have to be the reason it's
just that this is why we're
i don't go to work every day um
i mean if i had a real job i wouldn't go
to work every day
feeling like okay i got to do a good job
here so that i can
support the system and support the
government
no this is a normal thing
and and of course the problem is a lot
of the people on the left
especially the activists and so forth
who get upset at those of us
who want to keep our own money and who
don't want to pay
you know for example 62 percent in taxes
which which you are out of your ethic
mind to quote 50 cent
if you support that but a lot of people
don't understand this
um they don't pay anything in tax
because they don't have jobs
the activists who are out on the street
every single day it's pretty clear they
don't have jobs
so they just you know they got mommy and
daddy taking care of them either their
real mommy daddy or mommy daddy
government taking care of them
so they just don't understand how
demoralizing it is
and as i've said before i don't think
anyone even if you have a job and you
pay taxes even if you pay a lot of taxes
you still don't really understand how
bad the taxes are and how demoralizing
it really is or should be
until you've until you have physically
written checks to the government
if it's all w-2 withhold withholding
you don't re you still don't really
understand how bad it actually is
so you got to write that check
send it in watch the money leave your
bank account
okay number three disney has added
racism warnings to a number of its
classic films
um disney explains it this way this is
on their disney plus
streaming service i believe it says as
part of our ongoing commitment to
diversity and inclusion we are in the
process of reviewing our library and
adding
advisories to content that includes
negative depictions or mistreatment of
people or cultures
we can't change the past but we can
acknowledge it learn from it and move
forward together to create it tomorrow
that today can only hang on a second
learn from it and move forward together
to create a tomorrow
that today can only dream of
oh my good lord
this is disney we're talking about so i
guess i have to expect stuff like this
create a tomorrow that today can only
dream of
that is all right um
i'll just let that go then they go on to
explain why
many of their past films are
horrifically racist and offensive
um this is what they say about peter pan
for example
and my kids love this movie so i i read
this one with interest
because i my kids love it it wasn't my
favorite growing up but my kids
i've watched it with my kids a bunch of
times i i never noticed
really anything offensive about it i
never to me it just seemed like it's
it's a story about a kid who flies
around and fights a pirate
uh but disney they'll they will tell me
why i should be offended by their own
film this is what they say
the film portrays native people in a
stereotypical manner that reflects
neither the diversity of native peoples
nor their authentic cultural traditions
it shows them that it shows them
speaking in an unintelligible language
and repeatedly refers to them as
redskins an offensive term
peter and the lost boys engage in
dancing wearing headdresses and other
exaggerated tropes
a form of mockery and appropriation of
native peoples culture and imagery
that's pretty bad yeah
it's pretty bad when the magical boy who
flies
because of pixie dust is culturally
appropriating
you know he should know better if he
existed
he should know better then the
aristocats this is the
warning it says the cat is depicted as a
racist caricature of east asian peoples
with exaggerated stereotypical traits
such as slanted eyes and buck teeth he
sings in poorly accented english
by a by a voiced by a white actor and
plays the piano with chopsticks
this portrayal reinforces the perpetual
foreigner stereotype
while the film also features lyrics that
mock the chinese language and culture
such as
quote shanghai hong kong egg foo
young fortune cookie always wrong
i've never seen aristocats i might have
to check that out uh
swiss family robinson here's the
disclaimer there
the pirates who antagonize the robertson
family are portrayed as a stereotypical
foreign menace
many appear in quote yellow face or
brown face and are costumed in an
exaggerated
an exaggerated and inaccurate manner
with top-notch hairstyles
uh robes and overdone facial makeup and
jewelry reinforcing their barbarism and
otherness they speak in an
indecipherable language presenting a
singular and racist representation
of asian and middle eastern peoples okay
well you know that one's
really important too because you have to
make sure that uh you
portray pirates with sensitivity you'll
be very sensitive
to the pirates when you're portraying
them and they are a sensitive bunch
and so that's essential um
what does it really say about this it's
obviously ludicrous and embarrassing for
disney
but if if disney here here's really my
point if disney
had the courage of its convictions it
would just get rid of these movies
it would take them out of circulation
destroy them
uh save our children from being
corrupted by the racism and
bigotry because most kids who watch
peter pan anyway
probably can't read the disclaimer and
so now you're relying on parents to read
it for them and i can tell you
as as a parent i'm not going to read the
disclaimer to my kids i'm sorry i'm just
not going to read it
if they ask me daddy what does that say
i'll say i don't worry about it just
something stupid don't worry
and if i do read it i'll probably i
won't be able to help myself from
laughing while i read it
and that's going to send the wrong
message so my point is don't put the
ball in my court as a parent
you should just get rid of the movies
don't stream them
don't sell them on dvd or anything
um not merchandise get rid of all that
but they don't want to do that why is
that
if you've noticed they could they could
take that approach
that would really send the best message
and again if these are
really racist horrible movies then why
are you choosing to you're choosing to
stream them on your own platform while
you apologize
i'm so sorry for this i'm so sorry that
i'm showing you this right now as i show
it to you
i'm so sorry please forgive me while i
continue doing this thing right now that
i can stop doing
but they don't want to do that because
they make a lot of money uh they
make a lot of money from from some of
these properties i don't know how much
they make from aristocats but
they make a lot of money from peter pan
i'm sure um especially the
the merchandise and the the the the
peter pan
property and brand and all of that so
they want to they want the money
but they still want the wokeness so this
is just performative
fake wokeness which is all which is the
only kind of walkness we ever get
anymore of course
number four uh rush limbo limbaugh on
his show on
on monday had an update on his battle
with
lung cancer it wasn't a good update but
i thought i thought um his
whole segment on it was pretty powerful
i can't play the whole thing because of
several minutes long but
let me play just part of it what listen
to this from the moment you get the
diagnosis
there's a part of you every day okay
that's it life's over
you just don't know when but when you
get that diagnosis i mean that's
so during
the period of time after the diagnosis
you do what you can to prolong
life you do what you can to prolong a
happy
life you measure a happy life
against whatever medication it takes and
at
some point do you decide you know this
medication may be working but i hate
the way i feel over this is this i'm not
there yet
but but but it is part and parcel of
this
it's it's it's tough to realize
that the days where i
do not think i'm under a death sentence
are over now we all
are is the point we all
know that we're going to die at some
point but
when you have a terminal disease
diagnosis that has a time frame to it
then that puts a different
different psychological and and even
physical
awareness to it we are all under a death
sentence he says and that's that's true
that's a profound truth
one that i think most of us simply
refuse to accept
um certainly we don't want to think
about it we don't want to face the
implications
but rush limbaugh here is staring into
the abyss
facing down his own mortality his own
death and doing it with courage and
dignity
and you know the leftist critics of his
uh excitedly preparing to dance on his
grave
reveling in his suffering and i'm sure
you've seen if you go online and you
really want to see this sort of thing
you can go find it i don't know why
you'd want to see it but you can
um but all the ones doing that
we know that most of them will not have
the strength to confront their
death their impending death the way that
rush is confronting his
and that's what makes it so stupid by
the way so stupid to delight in another
person's death
or eventual death i mean obviously what
the people are doing with rush limbaugh
is also evil and vile and disgusting and
grotesque
from a moral standpoint but i'm talking
even as
aside from the morality of it it's
stupid because what do you think
you're going to live forever you don't
think this is going to happen to you
you will also be dead very soon
relatively speaking
you're what you're doing when you
delight in someone else's death and
suffering
you are essentially pointing and
laughing at someone
while they walk down a road that you are
also walking on
or maybe maybe a better analogy you're
on the same train
as them heading over the same cliff
and laughing as their train car goes
over the edge
well you're in a train car just a few
cars back
your time is coming in mere moments
relatively speaking you're going where
they're going you're under the same
sentence as he points out
so it's but i but i think
it it is it is in recognition of that
that's one of the reasons why people
react this way to the death sometimes to
death and especially
the deaths of people they don't like uh
it's a defense mechanism
it's a way of sort of convincing
themselves or pretending that this is
never going to happen to them
that death is somehow this sort of like
absurd abstract
far-off thing and something that only
happens to people they don't like
but that's not true and they'll get a
wake-up call um
but anyway a lot of dignity and courage
from rush limbaugh so god bless
god bless him um number five finally
we talked about dignity let's go to the
other end of the spectrum
uh headline in the wall street journal
says
men's nail polish is taking off why now
uh and then the the the subheading says
influenced by celebrities like bad bunny
harry styles and aesop rocky
i only know who one of those people are
harry styles is uh
who's what's he from he's a singer right
i sort of know him i don't know
bad bunny there's a male celebrity who
goes by
bad bunny
anyway it says young guys nationwide are
turning to nail polish
and companies are meeting the demand
with muted male
shades now i can't read the article
because it's behind the paywall and i'm
not going to pay for this kind of
content but
uh i don't really need to read it i can
simply answer
the question being posed in the in the
headline and by saying uh
it's it's not happening you're asking
why it's happening out it's not
it's not taking off this is what we call
an attempt at a self-fulfilling prophecy
and the media does this all the time
all the time especially when it comes to
masculinity and those sorts of things
they're always finding these absurd
effeminate styles
that like two guys are wearing and they
put out these headlines and saying
men everywhere are doing this look men
everywhere are wearing lipstick and yoga
pants
how did this style take off no it didn't
you just want it to you freaks that's
the difference
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future
content